لذا فإن أعمال الدراجات الثلاثة هي عمل
مثير للاهتمام للغاية أولاً وقبل كل شيء إنها
طريقة رائعة لربط العميل بأجزاء مختلفة
من مدينة واحدة خاصةً إذا نظرنا
إلى المشتري كمدينة لدي فقط ثلاثة
إلى أربعة أيام في المتوسط للسفر ور
ية  ما يمكن رؤيته في المدينة
وما نحاول القيام به هو الحصول على
أكثر الأماكن تفرداً أو الأماكن الأكثر
إثارة للاهتمام وعرض ذلك في
غضون 24 ساعة أو أقل إذا كان عليك
القيام بذلك بالسيارة أو مع السفر الآخر
قد يكون النقل ممكنًا ، فنحن
نقدم جولات قفز في 18
مدينة رائعة حول العالم
والفكرة الكاملة لجولتنا هي تقديم
مقدمة مثالية لعملائنا
إلى هذه المدن العظيمة مع
وجود الكثير من التحديات بوضوح في كل مدينة
تواجه دبي تحديات على الرغم من
أنها مدينة رائعة ،
إلا أنها تواجه تحديات لأن دبي
مدينة منتشرة للغاية ، لذلك نذهب إلى مدينة
مثل لندن حيث نقوم أيضًا بتشغيل
المدينة مزدحمة للغاية فيما يتعلق
بالمباني وهذه المواقع الآن
ج  هلسة من ذلك أولاً وقبل كل شيء
، أصبح الاثنان أطول قليلاً ، لذا
لا يمكننا أن نظهر لك في غضون ساعة جميع
مناطق الجذب الرئيسية ، أحد التحديات الكبيرة
هو المرور بالطبع ولكن
ما نحاول القيام به مع حركة المرور هو
التأكد من الجولة  أو يكون المرشد السياحي
ممتعًا للغاية بحيث تمتزج حركة المرور
في الخلفية وينتهي بك
الأمر بتجربة رائعة
لك